with the economy in a downturn Apple
computer needs to turn away from its
traditional markets of dot-com geeks
trust fund hipsters and people with a
deathly fear of sharp corners and
instead seek out new emerging markets
like retirees working part-time at gas
stations and people living out of camper
shells here are some new products that
are almost certainly coming soon from
Apple I survive this is a suite of
software applications for the downwardly
mobile former professional job scrape
searches craigslist for jobs that are at
least vaguely related to your former
profession for instance if you used to
be a user interface design engineer job
scrape will find you position shining
shoes bright side is a financial planner
that calculates all of your figures in
Italian lira so at least the numbers
look big and finally roughage is a handy
list of what tree bark and insects can
be safely Eden in case your food budget
is getting a little skimpy iPod yata
Apple gets into the low-end market with
a twenty-dollar mp3 player rather than
spending money on designing and
manufacturing new machines they just
slap new stickers on their secret cache
of Macintosh portables from 1989 these
new 16 pound iPods come with a whole
forty megabytes of hard drive space
enough to hold nearly an album to
support the ipod yata iTunes will now
mail you any song you buy on three and a
half inch floppies macbook vapor even
lighter than the macbook air the macbook
vapor drops the ounces by eliminating
the camera USB port video port trackpad
ram hard drive motherboard and replacing
the screen with a sheet of wax paper
what remains is essentially one of those
fake computers you see at furniture
stores but it still has the apple symbol
on it so it costs five hundred dollars
airport expropriate ER who can afford an
internet connection anymore the airport
x-pro
solves this little dilemma by doing
everything it can to use your neighbor's
connection including trying to default
passwords for routers searching for
hidden SSID s and trundling around like
a Roomba to find the one spot in your
apartment that you can get a single bar
from the library down the street the
iphone Steve Jobs can't bring himself to
cheap an apples most hits tarian product
but he does offer a compromise for five
dollars an hour you can rent an iphone
to bring to your next loft party dance
club or comic book convention just to
save face for an avid flat fee of ten
dollars an operator will call you and
stay on the line while you pretend that
it's a venture capitalist looking to
fund your next company for added
veracity the operator will be an actual
former venture capitalist